[MUSIC PLAYING]
EWA GASPEROWICZ:
Hello, everyone.
My name is Ewa Gasperowicz.
I'm a Developer Program
Engineer here at Google.
And I'm very happy to see
you here at today's session
and especially in the
beautiful city of Greco, which
I'm very proud of, so welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
My intention today
is to shed some light
on the process of transforming
an existing website
into a Progressive Web App.
Me and my team, we
recently went through a few
of such processes.
And I would like to share
with you some of the things we
found out on the way.
Probably by now, you've
heard a little bit
about Progressive Web Apps.
The notion of PWAs is making
rounds in the industry.
And also if you've
been, by any chance,
to some session about PWA--
who have been in the morning?
I've been there, yeah,
plenty of people--
you probably know
all of them by now.
But in a nutshell,
Progressive Web Apps
are experiences that
combine the best of the web
and the best of the apps.
They are web experiences,
which means they have
the wonderful reach of the web.
There is no installation.
And every new experience
is just one click away.
At the same time, they
use to the full extent
the capabilities of modern
apps and modern devices.
It means they are fast.
They don't make the user wait
for them to load or react.
They are integrated,
which means they
feel like a natural
part of your device.
They are ready-able, which
means they load and operate,
no matter the circumstances.
And they are engaging, which
means they give users pleasure
from using them.
This all sounds very
new and very exciting.
But is it really?
Some years back, when I first
got my hands on a smartphone
and started to browse
the web, I totally
expected it to work
just like on desktop.
My expectation was that,
if I visit the URL,
it actually loads, right?
That's not too much to ask.
And I expected it
to load quickly,
within my attention span.
And please mind
that people like me
don't want to get stuck on
the loading screen forever.
And for people like
me, the forever
usually means 30 seconds.
That's the reality we live in.
30 seconds, it's already
forever in mobile.
So I wanted it to load fast.
I wanted it to work smoothly,
so that I can actually
enjoy using the app.
And I wanted to have an easy
way to access the content
and be fully immersed
in the experience.
So those expectations
are pretty old.
It's not anything new
to expect your website
to work really well, just in the
way we describe Progressive Web
Apps.
So why do we even introduce this
concept of Progressive Web Apps
as a new concept, if all
we want to talk about
are actually websites just
done so well that the user has
a real pleasure from using it?
We use Progressive Web App
notion to build a mental model
and to communicate better
about our expectations
towards the modern web.
It just makes it easier for us
to wrap our heads around it.
It also allows us to
effectively communicate
the expectations and the
new possibilities that
are coming to the web.
And by talking about PWA, we
can encode those expectations
into different models.
Here, you can see
three of such models.
The first one is describing
behaviors of a Progressive Web
App, fast integrated,
ready-able, and engaging.
The second one is
a PW checklist.
If you just Google it and
go to the first result,
you will see a
checklist of features
that you can pay attention to in
order to enable progressiveness
in your app.
And finally, we
encode also a set
of rules in a tool
called Lighthouse.
Lighthouse can audit
a website and give you
a report how progressive
or not progressive it is.
So these are three
different models,
three different formats of
describing a Progressive Web
App.
But actually, the
notion is the same.
I'm going to use different
tools like this today
to talk about progressiveness
and how to achieve it
on your own websites.
OK, getting from a website
to a Progressive Web App
is a process.
It looks roughly like this.
As most of the projects, it
starts with a thought, an idea,
right?
In my case, thinking is
usually triggered by coffee.
So here we go, we
start with coffee.
And while drinking
coffee, you can also
ponder about the
scope of the project,
about the things
you want to achieve.
After that, once you're
done with your coffee,
you can go and
analyze your website
to understand your
starting point.
You need to have
a reference point,
once you are done
implementing PWA features,
to know how you did.
Next step is to prioritize.
The truth is, we rarely have
the resources to implement all
of this stuff at once, right?
And the cool thing about PWA
is that it's a modular concept.
It's not a monolithic
technology.
You can actually pick and
choose what to implement
and in what order.
And I'm going to talk a
little bit about that later.
You should always
set your priorities
according to your user base
and your business needs.
So always talk to
your stakeholders
while prioritizing PWA features.
Then, you should
prepare your tools.
Every job is easier
when you choose
the right tools to perform it.
Finally, you can just
execute your plan,
implement the features.
I'll talk about some issues that
you can encounter at this step,
although it's a
very broad topic.
And by no means I can
be exhaustive here.
At the end, there is
sometimes an overlooked step,
the evaluation,
measure, and evaluate.
It gives you both a
nice summary of how
you did in your
migration from web sites
to Progressive Web Apps.
But it can also be a very
valuable starting point
for your next iteration
on the project.
This is how the
process looks like.
And we're going to follow it
throughout this presentation.
OK, so while
drinking our coffee,
let's talk about
the scope of PWA,
what this notion
actually includes.
We know the goal, that we want
to deliver the delightful user
experience.
But what are the actual,
practical deliverables?
Usually, when we
talk about PWA, we
talk about these three
core technologies first.
We talk about Service Worker
and related techniques
like caching.
They allow you to offer your
users an offline experience.
But also, they can
improve reliability
of your app, which can now load
no matter the circumstances
and also positively
influence the speed
for your second-time visitors.
Push notifications allow you
to send the right message
and bring them back to
your app or re-engage them.
Add to Home Screen allows
you to make your app feel
like a first-class
citizen on your mobile.
The user can install
it to their home screen
and access it easily,
making it easy for them
to go back to your app again.
And all of it, of
course, is enabled
by HTTPS, which is a bottom
line of a secure web experience.
I like to call these three
features a native parity core.
Because they actually
allow us, these days,
to do on the web the same
things that just recently
were possible only
on native apps.
And while they make me super
excited about the future
of the web, I think there is
much more to Progressive Web
Apps than just
the native parity.
Well, let's fill some
of this white space.
Let's add the
performance factor.
I cannot stress enough how
important it is to make
your site fast and performant,
preferably even before you
implement Service Worker,
push, and Add to Home Screen.
Making sites performant
includes a lot of techniques,
like optimizing your
assets, especially images,
blocking scripts, and making
good use of browser cache.
Getting this part right
is especially important
for your first
time visitors, who
do not have a Service Worker
yet or are on browsers that
don't fully support it yet.
They have to rely on network
in order to get to your site.
So by making it more
performant, using
a lot of available
techniques, you'll
make life easier
for them as well.
As a matter of fact,
going for PWA features
is in general a very
good audit opportunity,
not only for performance
issues, but also for UX issues
and for other problems
with your site.
It is crucial to make
your website of generally
good quality before adding the
additional complexity of PWA
features.
I personally call
it PWA readiness.
Especially if you plan
to implement offline
down the line, you need to be
respectful of user resources,
like bandwidth and memory.
And you don't want to
push to the user's cache
a bloated website.
Similarly, you don't want
to send push notifications
to the user, only for him
to come back to your site
and discover he cannot perform
the action he was asked to do
because your forms are
convoluted or are not
accessible, right?
So first, remember to fix the
basic issues with your site
and only then move on
to the PWA features.
All right, our site is PWA
ready, it's performant.
We already have an idea of how
to implement Service Worker,
push, and Add to Home Screen.
Is it all we need to care about?
Well, the web is
always evolving.
And only recently,
two features were
added to the platform,
credentials management
and payments.
And I'm pretty sure there
will be more APIs coming
that will make your user
experience even better
on your website.
So you always need to keep an
open mind about what's coming
and what you can use
in your projects.
Finally, all of this
is nothing if you
don't open up with a great UX.
Good UX drives engagement.
And without it, you might find
that the gain from implementing
all the underlying features
is less than expected,
just as I described
with the push
or with the Service Worker.
So always make sure that
all of these features
are tied by a nice
and smooth UX.
Finally, it's always a great
comfort and a good practice
to make decisions based on data.
For this, you need to
measure things, both before
and after the implementation
of the PWA feature,
actually throughout
the whole process.
So that's the full scope, in
my opinion, of PWA concepts.
It's much more than just
the Service Worker, right?
These are all the areas you
should take into account,
or at least think
about when investing
how to approach adding
PWA features to your site.
Well, that's a big chart,
and a lot to digest,
and quite a monster.
So how do you eat an elephant?
I've heard one
mouthful at a time.
So let's start.
We had our coffee.
We understand the
scope of our project.
Let's actually start it.
We start with analysis.
First, you need to audit
the website in order
to understand the
current state of the app.
And in order to do that, we
provide a very good tool,
Lighthouse.
Lighthouse is a great tool
for website diagnostics.
It's a Chrome
extension that allows
you to measure how close your
web app is to a Progressive Web
App.
When you install the
extension, Lighthouse,
and run your website
through it, it
gives you back a score and
a report that summarizes
the state of your app for you.
This is how the average
report might look like, right?
There are different areas where
you need to pay attention to.
And there is also a long
list with explanations
why your website got
this score and not
another, together with the links
of how to make things better.
So apart from being
a diagnostic tool,
it's also a very good
educational tool,
because just by checking
a report for your website,
you can learn a
lot about how you
can make this website better.
One feature I wanted to
call out is the Share button
in the top right corner.
Apart from sharing,
it allows you to save
this report in JSON format.
I really encourage you
to save your report
before you start any projects.
Because it provides you a
benchmark and a reference point
that you can compare to
once your project finishes.
Of course, Lighthouse is
not the only tool available.
There are other ones.
And most of them
actually also allow you
to save the data somewhere.
So if you have only 15
minutes to analyze your site,
record and save the results
from the tools mentioned
above, Lighthouse, the security
panel in Chrome Dev Tools, page
speed insights, web page test.
It will allow you to understand
the standing of your site,
but also provide a
reference for comparison
after implementation.
All right, so we
analyzed our website.
We saved our snapshots of data.
And we know exactly how it
performs in different areas.
Now, it's time to prioritize.
All areas I mentioned, you
should take into account.
So the question
is, where to start?
I would say, start at
the beginning, Ensure PWA
readiness.
No amount of PWA features will
solve unresponsive clutter
or a janky website.
So before you add
new complexity,
you want your site to be
as lean, smooth working,
and optimized as
reasonably possible.
In particular, based
on your outcome,
of course, because
each site differs,
you might look into the
areas like optimizing images,
easy thing and really brings big
gains; remove unnecessary code;
leverage browser caching, before
you even switch to a Service
Worker; avoid blocking
code; and divide
big, monolithic JavaScript
into smaller chunks,
if adequate for your website.
These are common things
that are very well known.
But as your website
evolves over time,
sometimes they're overlooked
and they go off track.
So going for PWA is
actually a great moment
to stop for a moment, audit
them again, and fix the issues,
if you encounter any.
Let me show you an example.
Some time ago, I was working
on the WomanTechmaker.org site.
I was doing exactly that.
I was preparing it for
some upcoming PWA features.
Here, you can see the network
panel of the Chrome Dev Tools.
What I did here, I just
sorted the assets by size.
And focusing only on the
very top of this list,
you can pin down the best
targets for optimization.
Here, the two biggest files
were the YouTube API file
and the hero image you
can see on the home page.
So the question was
how to optimize those.
Well, let's start
with the hero image.
It's a hero image.
So it covers the whole viewport.
So it needs to be
as big as viewport.
But it doesn't need to
be bigger than that.
So I just created two other
versions of this file.
I saved the medium
and small images.
I added a few
breakpoints to my CSS.
And as an outcome on
the medium size page,
I got a 21% gain of lower weight
of the images on that site.
And this all took maybe six
minutes altogether to perform.
And this 21% gain, just
by optimizing one image.
Really, small improvements can
lead to big gains in this area.
Similarly, I was able to replace
heavy assets with simpler ones.
Previously, we used the
Player API for YouTube video
on the page, which
today is actually
possible to do
with Simple iframe
with the correct configuration
to embed the video.
So I just replaced
it with the iframe.
And the whole 400
kilobytes of YouTube API
disappeared from my site, right?
And it's one line of code.
It's very easy to do.
Similarly, we
realized that we don't
use the full extent
of the load-library,
we just use few functions.
So we can replace
it with the core.
It brings us from 24
kilobytes to four kilobytes.
And maybe 20 kilobytes
is not a great deal
of amount of download data, but
those small gains do add up.
Finally, we started to leverage
browser caching better.
In the previous
version of the site,
we were versioning our
assets by the build version.
This means that with
each build of our site,
this number changed and
the name of the file
changed, which means the browser
would need to download it
again, even if this particular
asset did not change,
just because the overall
build for this site changed.
So we switched it to the
content-based hashing instead.
Now, only if the content
of the file changes,
we change the hash and
therefore the filename.
And this way, we can
optimize the browser caching.
This allows users to
download much less resources
than in the previous use case.
So you can see all of those
changes were pretty simple
and were very easy to achieve.
And they did add up to
big gains on our website.
Once you are PWA
ready, you should
ensure safety of your users.
We want to develop great
Progressive Web Apps in order
to leverage the frictionless
and accessible web out there.
But the web is also dangerous.
So keeping your users
safe is hugely important.
So I would go for HTTPS
as one of the first things
to implement on your
site, if you go for PWA.
Also, a lot of new
web APIs actually
require HTTPS to be
enabled on your site.
So it should be a
natural step to take.
Once your site is
PWA ready and secure,
you can simply follow
your business needs.
And this pretty much depends on
your site and on your business.
For example, if user acquisition
is important for your business,
you should focus on perf.
Because performance
site that loads
quickly on the
first visit allows
you to gain some more users.
If you have a huge bounce rate
because of unperformant site,
a lot of users don't even see
your site in the first place.
So for user acquisition, you
might want to focus on perf.
If you care about users that
are in low connectivity areas
or in, I don't know,
London Tube maybe, then you
should focus offline, on
implementing Service Worker
and the offline experience.
Because this is where the
big gain for your users is.
User retention?
Focus on push and
Add to Home Screen.
This allows you to reengage
users in your experience.
And you can pick and choose
because PWA is modular.
And you can see which areas
benefit your business best.
Now we're choosing the tools.
And there is a lot of
tools out there, right?
There is a lot of tools.
There are some starter
packs and generators
for different
frameworks and libraries
that allow you to
build a Progressive Web
App from scratch.
But I want to focus on migrating
an existing website to a PWA.
That's why I will give a shout
to one library in particular.
It's the Workbox library.
When developing
offline experience,
things might get a
little bit fiddly.
There is also a
lot of boilerplate
because many tasks are simply
repetitive, like caching.
So my advice is, don't
do things by hand.
They might bite you.
Remove both stress and
boilerplate with Workbox.
And luckily, at
quarter to three,
we have a wonderful
workshop for you
from website to PWA with
Workbox on the third floor.
So if you want to see all
the ins and outs and gains
you can get from this
library for your website,
go and check out the training.
Yay, finally, we
got to the point
where we can implement
our PWA features.
This is the hardest part
to give any generic advice
on because it differs a lot
from project to project, right?
So instead, let
me share with you
an example of how we solved an
offline dilemma in the Women
Techmaker site.
I think it shows nicely
the type of problems
you need to solve when
implementing PWA features,
in this case offline.
So this is a Women Techmaker
site seen as online.
And it's a beautiful site.
It's a very rich,
visual experience,
lots of images, a really,
really nice looking site.
And I was supposed to implement
offline experience for it.
If I wanted to save
all of this to cache,
that would be very, very heavy.
So caching all the images
was rather a no go.
How about new images?
Well, this site
looks kind of ugly.
But it's also unusable.
I can't even go to a
different sub page.
Because the Menu
button is missing.
So it's totally unusable.
Therefore, caching no
images is also a no go.
How do we find a middle point?
How do we negotiate this?
Well, I took a deeper
look at the website
to really understand
its structure.
I divided images by function.
Let's take a look.
The yellow images are the
navigational and action images.
They are there so that users
can navigate and perform
some activities on our website.
Therefore, they're
crucial for the site
to be fully functional.
Then, the red ones are
branding and priority.
They allow you to
connect with your user.
They're very important.
For example, thanks
to them, the user
recognizes which site
they're looking at, right?
So they are high
priority images.
Then the blue ones
are decorative.
They make the side look nice.
They add to the experience.
But if they're missing, they
don't really break anything.
The site is slightly less rich.
But it's still usable.
And the third type of
picture, the green ones,
I call informative.
It means they look nice.
They add to the graphical
layer of the site.
But they also convey
some message within them.
So how do we deal with those
four different types of images?
Well, for navigation
and action images,
I just inline them with SVG.
They're usually small.
They're icon-like.
So it's easy to do.
And if you embed them in
your HTML, if you cache HTML,
they're going to
always be there, right?
So problem solved.
You don't even need to come
up with caching strategy
with them.
Because if the HTML is there,
your images are there as well.
Now, branding and priority.
I want for them
to always be there
because they're
important for me, because
of my business case.
So I precache them.
It means when user enters
the site, in this case,
I precache them with
the Workbox library.
I just push them
to the user cache
because they are important.
And without them, their
experience will be broken.
Now, decorative, I employed
the runtime cache strategy,
which means, as user
navigates through the site
and is online, I download those
pictures and save to the cache.
Because there is high
likelihood that the user
will want to go
back to those sites
later on when they're offline.
But if the user doesn't venture
to some parts of my site,
I just show a fallback
instead, a placeholder, right?
The site maybe looks less
rich, but it's still usable.
And I didn't blow
the user's cache
with a lot of decorative images.
Now, informative images
are fancy ones in the slot.
Because here, I use full
power of Service Worker.
Service worker is just
a JavaScript file,
which means you can put
a lot of logic into it.
Here, I wanted to be able not to
save all the logos to the user
cache, but still convey the
message, who are the sponsors?
So instead of the logos,
I generate the images
on the fly in Service
Worker, using the alt text
from the image stack, right?
So instead of saving
all the images,
I generate them on the fly
to not have a real image
but still convey the message.
And this is just
an example of how
you can deal with images and
four different strategies.
The message I want to convey
is that you should really
look deeply into the
structure of your site
and type of content you
have, and try to divide it,
and come up with
different strategies
to different parts
of your content.
And this way, you can provide
the best user experience
for your users while offline.
OK, once we
implement everything,
we need to evaluate the site.
And it's often an
overlooked step.
Remember when I told you to
save the snapshots of data
from before the implementation?
Well, now, they come in handy.
You can go again through
the audit procedure
and record all the
same stack traces
and compare the outcome
with the previous version.
Hopefully, it will
give you a surge
of joy, as you see metrics
improve on your site.
However, there is one caveat.
Metrics are helpful.
But they're only metrics.
Getting a 100 on
Lighthouse feels great.
I can assure you it
feels really good.
And it may also help to
convince your stakeholders
about the impact you achieved
or maybe get your project
funding for the next iteration.
But it does not answer how the
users are finding your changes,
right?
And as a matter of
fact, PWA influences
many areas of your app.
It influences the UX.
For example, now,
you need to consider
a lot of offline
scenarios, for example,
how users will try to
buy your product when
they're in an offline mode.
It influences your workflow.
You need to add things
to users' cache.
And it's very hard to manage
this process manually.
So maybe you need to invest
into some build tools
and into your
workflow optimization.
It influences your measuring.
Now, a lot of interaction
of your user with your site
might happen when
they're offline, right?
So you need to implement
offline analytics.
And it might also
influence your SEO.
So you should check if
nothing's changed there
or if the things were even
improved on the SEO part.
So that's the process.
That's how we got from
the website to PWA.
First, we analyzed the website.
And then we prioritized
and we chose the features
we wanted to focus on.
We get a set of tools to
perform those actions.
Then we implemented our changes.
And then we evaluated.
And the important
thing is this can
be an iterative process, right?
Each ending point
where you measure
can be also a starting
point for the next iteration
of your website.
The web develops, and your
websites will develop over time
as well, and your user
needs will change over time,
so you need to keep
going back and checking
what can be done to provide
better experience for them.
Luckily, you're not
alone in this road
for perfection of your website.
There is a lot of resources.
And a lot of them are
available to you today
at this conference.
There is Lighthouse tool.
You can use it both as a
Chrome extension and online.
And there is one real life
Lighthouse on the first floor.
So feel free to give it a try.
There are site clinics where
you can consult the healthiness
of your site with Googlers.
They have been on
the third floor.
We had some office hours.
If you have any questions
after the session
or want to talk to me, I'll
be present in the office hours
area on the third floor
after the session.
There is the Instructor Led
Training, quarter to three,
that walks you through Workbox.
And of course, there is the
Progressive Web Apps section
on developers.Google.com
that I really
encourage you to try out.
Thank you very much.
I hope you enjoyed the session.
And see you around.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]